dans cette petite exploitation du loiret
les fleurs de safran pointe déjà le bout
de leur nez
l'automne c'est la saison idéale pour la
récolte dans le gâtinais il existe une
dizaine de producteurs qui ramassent
entre 2 et 4 kilo de safran par an c'est
une culture unique il ya peu de plantes
qu'on valorise par leurs fleurs la
plupart des plantons la valorise par
leurs fruits et surtout une culture
atypique par son cycle qui est inversée
par rapport au plan de cancun unique les
pisse l'êtes aussi par son prix comptez
35 euros le gramme alors chaque fleur
compte l safran est une fleur fragile
ça sort le matin donc on va celle ci
elle et elle est sortie à quelques il ya
quelques heures
elle s'ouvrira demain et demain soir
elle sera déjà pourri donc tous les
matins il faut ramasser les fleurs et
l'après midi en les aimant et mende et
comprenait éplucher les fleurs de safran
pour en extraire le stigmate ce
filaments rouges qui une fois infuser
dans une sauce embellie des plats
l'avantagent de s'avancer contre le mcs
aussi bien sûr du salé du sucré l'entrée
le plat le dessert on peut vraiment
l'approprier à tout type de plat et
finalement même se fasse un premier chef
il faut dire sublimer un produit tout à
fait ordinaire et le révéler à part
justement toutes ses saveurs
depuis trois ans ce restaurant du
malesherbois propose des recettes à base
de safran récoltés dans le gâtinais
safran s'écrire excellent et on peut
travailler faire travailler nos
producteurs locaux une économie locale
plutôt que d'aller acheter du safran
ailleurs qui sera de moins bonne qualité
et puis un jour on aura plus de
producteurs en local sera de la france
produit chaque année 100 kg de cet or
rouge à la renommée internationale